foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong my name is Mark Ellis and this is
one of our After Dark episodes which
means we're gonna talk about movies
especially on this particular episode of
the program but that conversation could
extend to sprawling Recaps of our
personal lives how are our dogs doing
who are we dating way back in 1998 why
that year well because this year is
actually the 25th anniversary of rotten
tomatoes so we may say the Tomato meat
is wrong from time to time on this show
but we love being here at Rotten
Tomatoes celebrating his 25th birthday
this year the actual birthday of Rotten
Tomatoes is I believe August 18th I want
to say and so we're gonna get into the
history of Rotten Tomatoes but I can't
do this show alone and in the stead of
Jacqueline Coley who is still at home
recovering from just covering award
season which is uh it's a long and
arduous task so she's chilling and
relaxing while we have Clark wolf and
Winston a marshall back in studio it was
a fantastic chat that the three of us
had last week about Keanu Reeves movies
and some which we think unfairly
maligned films of Keanu Reeves that were
right on the Tomato Meter not according
to us talk knock knock The Replacements
Hardball and so now we're just here for
an after dark episode talking about the
Rotten Tomatoes 25th anniversary uh
Winston you know from The Capes and cows
weekly show you also know him as a
comedian and actor he's seen him pop up
on a bunch of TV shows commercials
always great to have Winston back and
Clark wolf who made a sterling debut so
good last week we brought you back and
also very exciting because you have a
short film coming out called a shining
example but also tomorrow in theaters
Nationwide you can catch your new movie
mail them it's in theaters across the
country I'm so excited I am please go
see it in the theater because it is it's
only going to be in the theaters it's
not going to be on VOD or Blu-ray and
it's a horror movie it's fun to see
those in theaters the effect it's
practical effects the Russells who did
the new uh Hellraiser movie
um and among other things did our
practical effects and they are awesome
can you just like send me like a 4K
Blu-ray because like I'm not trying to
be up in the back oh Lord no Jesus I if
I may this is I think this will interest
your audience since it is a an after
dark episode so uh around Christmas time
my family tries to find alternative
Christmas movies you know to watch okay
and you know there is a tradition in
it's in the Christmas carol you know
like there'll be scary ghost stories and
you know like ghost stories so um yeah I
mean it's good it's a ghost story
Charles Dickens classic is a ghost story
it used to be a tradition a Christmas
tradition so I suggested The Conjuring 2
um which is a Christmas movie it takes
place at Christmas this is why I love
Clark because she does not mess around
she's not like let's just dip our toe in
here she's like let me just rip your
Christmas loving heart out
my God you're going for blood there are
trees Christmas trees and Christmas
carols and anyway so oh thank you cards
that's gonna make it so much easier for
Winston
so I convinced my parents they're like
okay great idea it's like there's no sex
there's no there's no language there's
no idea that's fair and so we want my
dad
who used to play football for the
University of Georgia and went on to
play professionally in the CFL large man
yes yes uh we got maybe 20 minutes into
The Conjuring and he was he was
literally jumping out of his chair and
he was like I'm I'm really sorry
everyone but I I can't I can't I cannot
watch this man after my own heart so I I
did longer than you did in the contract
future daughter be like Daddy Let's
watch it on YouTube why don't you go to
your room I'm not absolutely not so the
funny part of the story is I DM James
one and I told him this story and he
wrote me back and he was like first of
all he was like that's amazing but
second of all he said it's always the
it's always the tough guys Jason Statham
told me the exact same oh yeah he was
like I cannot watch your movies they're
too scary for me and I was like well my
dad's in good company but yes so oh the
big tough guys big action guys being
like no James Juan no dad and Jason
Statham running towards trouble unless
that trouble is an undead nun perhaps
and then you get I mean if celebrate
your holidays how you want to celebrate
your holidays your birthdays I really
don't celebrate my birthday that much
I'm not I actually love getting older I
embrace the process of sitting in a
rocking chair and yelling at kids but I
don't do a lot for my birthday are you a
big birthday party person Clark I used
to be before kovid okay covid kind of
broke me with birthdays I I my birthday
is in a couple of weeks and I have made
no thank you and I'm thinking actually
that this this weekend uh I might take
some friends to go see malum that might
be like my birthday celebration that's a
good point because it's close enough
yeah it's your birthday it's allowed to
be about you but I mean it's a great
film and you happen to be one of the
stars of it so uh Winston do you take
people to see your new movie in theaters
on your birthday
absolutely and if I don't have a new one
I'm like we're gonna watch that episode
of that show I did like a couple years
ago it's gonna be fun we did something
for your birthday last year right yes
was there a thing yeah yeah no
absolutely so I I went to a bar it was a
very nice bar setup you had so what I
what I did I'm I'm I'm I'm big into
themes
um and so 35 I was having trouble
figuring out what team I wanted to do
okay so what I ended up doing is I ended
up recreating or attempting to recreate
all 34 previous birthdays as birthday
number 35 and then when I got too
ambitious I changed it to there was
childhood like kind of adolescence 20s
and then like adulthood and so like the
first half was like laser tag and mini
golf and like since there's no arcade we
went Dave and Busters and then we
transitioned into like the teen College
year so we had like a house party with
beer pong and all that stuff and then
like the adult one is like you go to a
nice bar you maybe have a couple shots
here and there but you kind of keep it
classy and then you go home and pass out
and so I I saw it at the bar and I
didn't realize he was doing like a whole
Richard link later
life kind of thing but I was surprised
you were still standing because I knew
that beer pong was early in the day and
unfortunately you'd all know I love
playing beer pong I'm pretty damn good
at it but I I was surprised that you
were still upright because you had all
that partying but you still seem pretty
lucid and like able to celebrate your
birthday competently it was because
since I really took the childhood thing
to heart I didn't drink at all in the
beginning until we got to Dave and
Buster's and even then it was like a
drink oh did you have juice boxes
oh a Capri Sun for Winston's birthday
Sunny Dean Capri Sun baby it was amazing
purple stuff give it to me absolutely uh
but once we got to the house party it
was it was No Holds Barred I think it's
just I had mentally prepared all day
make sure you're eating drinking a lot
of water take your vitamins because this
is like a marathon not just Sprint geez
so that that's the only reason you saw
me in like any sort of like normal
condition I loved it because like if you
you're in college and like you you're
that age or your mid-20s like you have
that idea to doing a birthday party
where it's going to celebrate like what
Rotten Tomatoes are probably going
through right now with turning 25 hey
congrats you can now Rent A Car by
yourself but you're thinking like oh I
can do this whole look back at my life
you're not mature enough to do that yet
and handle it like Winston did because
that's a 35 year old man studying this
and being like okay I need to Pace
myself back in our 20s we didn't really
Pace ourselves all that much at least we
weren't all that good at pulling it off
and so Rotten Tomatoes one of the things
they're doing to celebrate their
birthday which is going to be a
year-long celebration is releasing this
new card game that is so much fun to
play and you can play in a variety of
different ways you can involve the
Tomato Meter the audience score our hand
model Winston is showing you exactly how
it works reminded me of I think an
all-time great card game that should be
played in Vegas Uno oh yeah because
there's wild cards so you got a couple
wild cards and and you can give hints
into the movie whoever gets the movie
first you can play a number of different
ways and that's available at rt.com
shop so you need a card game if your
family around the holidays isn't into
watching horror movies then you can play
the Rotten Tomatoes card game all the
year we are not gonna let this go for
the rest of the show no we're not going
to torture we're not I guess I'm never
meeting Clark's family if this is if
this is what they do for family time
this is going to be outside caroling
that's as close as
well
like to literally walk about my family I
don't go over there that's crazy
because somebody possessed in that house
we don't keep walking I want to give a
big shout out to the the founder the
creator of Rotten Tomatoes I should say
so Rotten Tomatoes was launched in
effect on August 18th by sen Duong who
was a fan of Jackie Chan movies
primarily and so it's like how can I get
this comprehensive list of Jackie Chan
films as they're coming out in the
United States because after Rumble in
the Bronx there was like sort of a I
guess Western reunited interest in
Jackie Chan who was a you know Superstar
she's forever and so now you have this
collection and the first movie that was
going to be on Rotten Tomatoes was gonna
be the greatest movie of all time rush
hour the greatest movie of all time but
rush hour's release date got delayed it
still became a big hit in September and
so the first movie that ended up being
on Rotten Tomatoes that was not
affiliated with Jackie Chan was your
friends and neighbors so not quite the
at the rush hour became never even heard
of it yeah I think we can give Rush Hour
credit for being one of The Inspirations
along with Jackie Chan so thank you so
much to uh sen Duong for creating this
thing that we all know and love and
celebrate and kind of use as a guideline
I call it the scoreboard for movies
where if you're looking at the Tomato
Meter it may not necessarily reflect
your opinions and we have this whole
podcast dedicated to when we think the
Tomato Meter is right and wrong but it's
just a nice barometer and now we have
the verified audience score to kind of
gauge oh okay I agree more with the
audience on this one with the Critics on
this one so what let's start this
conversation off by going back to 1998
when sen was just creating Rotten
Tomatoes it was a twinkle in his eye
where was Winston Marshall in 1998 what
were you doing what were your dreams
what were your Ambitions well my parents
were getting divorced uh that's good
memories
well I mean look you talk about a
formative year in somebody's existence
well and this is what's so funny is I
think I mean that may have just gotten
really personal all of a sudden but uh
from the standpoint of I felt like all
of a sudden I saw every movie because of
that there was this weird thing where
like either with my friends or my aunts
and uncles I was at the movies all the
time that escapism
um and when you talk about you mentioned
earlier but off camera everybody loves
to talk about 99 and what 99 was for
movies 98 had bangers like oh we already
talked about the greatest move of all
time rush hour which just chef's kiss
but just some of the highlights because
I want other people to be able to chime
in on this y'all should have seen
Winston right before we went to air he
was circling oh my gosh he was starring
stuff he's got a ranking system give us
some of your your favorites from 98.
first of all 98 I would have been about
to turn 11 so I'm about 10 years old
Pokemon the first movie came out don't
act like that didn't come through with
every child was out here in these
streets just like this is incredible but
you had He Got Game uh The Truman Show
Mulan The Mask of Zorro The Parent Trap
um ants the water boy Enemy of the State
of Bug's Life you got mail Small
Soldiers and a personal rom-com favorite
six days and seven nights oh wow oh okay
the Harrison Ford Anne Heche classic to
some including you yes sir I didn't know
you were that but what is it about Six
Days Seven Nights that just spoke to
your soul the same thing that I guess
Air Force One did what Han Solo in like
on a tropical island with a hot lady
okay I'll watch it like I just I mean he
doesn't do a bad job of selling that
movie Clark I mean when you look back on
your 1998 it doesn't have to be as
dramatic as Winston's but where were you
in your in your sort of uh relationship
with movies in your life where you live
and all that good stuff I was definitely
a a nerdy middle schooler Who Loved
movies who definitely had a subscription
to Entertainment Weekly uh and who was
uh you know I grew up in a suburb of
Atlanta so I was certainly at the mall
on the movies every weekend my dad took
me to a lot of a lot of movies every
weekend and
um you know I think that this is like
the formative it's funny like we all
play and played in a movie trivia league
for a long time and these are the movies
that like really sunk in uh and and
stuck um because I think they did come
out for me at least during those
formative those formative years yeah and
then it's a car's point if you watch the
first season of the movie trivia
schmodern in particular when I was
writing a lot of the questions most of
them are about the list of movies that
Winston just rattled off I mean I'll say
I I knew 98 as an interesting year in
the movies for a couple reasons for me
so I was writing my college application
essays and thinking like I'm not getting
into Notre Dame but let's take a shot
I'm probably gonna end up at you know
some East Coast school maybe something
in the ACC maybe Virginia Tech a Florida
State maybe a Wake Forest we'll see if I
become a demon Deacon like my father
before me but in the midst of all that
you also had these movies that were
mirroring each other like you said we
had ants and A Bug's Life we had Deep
Impact and Armageddon so it's like these
similar themes kind of coming through
the big movie I think of every time I
think in 1998 and I'm not saying it's
the best movie from 98 because it
certainly isn't pretty good version of
cashmere is Godzilla because in
Williamsburg Virginia where we had a
movie theater that I worked at for a
couple Summers it was not the best movie
theater to go see a flick at Hampton
Virginia had jet which is a couple Towns
over had just opened their AMC I think
it was a AMC 24 and it's like oh this is
gonna be this is the biggest thing and
it opened the weekend of Godzilla that
whole week in school I me and my friend
we were just not sure about how excited
we were for Godzilla we went to go see
it Thursday night like the first show we
possibly could I fell asleep I fell
asleep in Godzilla opening night how
because it's so bad and boring no it's
not terrible I as a child I loved it
there was a mutant lizard and it's
little babies all over New York what are
you talking about and on top of that you
had Professor Frank Professor Frank he
makes you laugh he makes you think
running the camera the entire time oh my
God how do we saw a different movie with
all the Velociraptors running around
Madison Square Garden like that movie
was such a misfire and I think maybe I
was just too excited and baby needed a
nap at some point y'all know me pretty
well you know I need my daily naps I
didn't get a nap that week and so I was
really excited we go to the you know we
go to class go to the movie theater
before the the movie started they had
one of the employees come out front and
do Godzilla trivia so this is one of the
formations of my movie trivia career
they asked the easy question I think
first was like what city does is
Godzilla famous for stomping in Japan
and like some guy want to teach her for
saying Tokyo and I'm like you know what
I'm gonna hold out for the hard question
he's like what's what Perry Mason Star
was in Godzilla in 1985 and I ripped my
hand shot up they called me I was like
Raymond Burr got the T-shirt impressed
the theater full of ongoing onlookers
and uh hence the movie trivia Showdown
was born
the colonel was planted in the microwave
for it to pop so I will say two very two
questions about the 1998 Godzilla does
sound like the movie trivia
it really does is the precursor too at
that movie theater trivia but so that
that's the movie that I sort of think of
when I think of 1998 and it was also a
big interesting year at the Oscars
because you had Saving Private Ryan
which I think a lot of people thought
was going to win best picture at the
ensuing 99 Oscars and it was Shakespeare
in Love that took that title so a lot of
cool stuff happening in 1998 the
ceremony of the Oscars that was held in
98 was hosted by the legendary Billy
Crystal and that is where Titanic took
home 11 statues the 1997 release so a
lot of cool stuff going on in the world
of movies but then we also look at these
movies that we see from 1998 if you had
to pick a movie from our list or from
something else Clark what is the movie
do you think maybe still stands up to
the test of time the best oh wow well
that's a really hard question oh my gosh
for Winston we know he's going to say
Rush Hour regardless of whether he
thinks it's true pretty much
yikes I don't know what stands a test of
time because some of these I would argue
absolutely do not
um but you know the the one that's
jumping out at me as kind of one of the
last of its kind is The Mask of Zorro
um just a really like a big budget
practical stunts Adventure that is
perfectly cast with a really wonderful
love story and uh stakes and uh
chemistry between its leads got that
loose swashbuckling kind of nature to it
I just feel like we don't sincerely or
earnestly make movies like that anymore
and I this is one that for me has has
stayed wonderful and just watching all
the horses and the stunts and the sword
fighting and Antonio Banderas is so good
that's the first time I remember seeing
Catherine Zeta Jones and being like wow
she's a star that's a good point though
it's like you really don't see a lot of
movies like The Mask of Zora anymore
this is one that I think I've seen is
probably an animated film which would be
the Adventures of Tintin kind of
reminded me of like that like your
Indiana Jones's so another Stephen
Stevens bielberg did produce The Mask of
Zorro so maybe there you go the
connective tissue I mean I it's it's so
funny that because also in 1998 Google
was this thing that happened and
speaking of Google I Googled movies from
1998 do you know what came up what came
up do you know what came up first movie
that comes up three movies uh blade from
1998 which I will talk about in a minute
for why blade is such an important movie
the next movie I believe is called a
very unlucky leprechaun
yeah that's the next movie that Google
told me came out in 1998 I don't even
know if it's on the Tomato Meter if
critics saw it if audiences saw it a
very unlucky leprechaun it stars Tim
Matheson as like the dad and then
there's this leprechaun it is not in the
Leprechaun horror franchise however
guess who plays this very unlucky
leprechaun Warwick freaking Davis what
you cannot keep that guy from playing a
leprechaun even if it's not in his
franchise Leprechaun the horror movies I
believe this is like a nice
light-hearted dromeday everything that
you just said sounds like Mad Libs to me
honestly a very weird
an unlucky leprechaun Davis
1998. what oh and speaking of the 90s
Mad Libs how great were Madlibs back in
the day that's pretty awesome yeah so
the other movie that came out was was
Major League back to the miners and I'm
like that's the movie guarantee you that
this is because that is not the three
movies that came up for me
have have modified so for me we've
parted ways in the metaverse so you want
top picks for you or you went just
popular 1998 movies I typed in movies
from 1998. how did you go and I'll tell
you what I Googled so the three that it
gave me one that makes us the first one
the Avengers which I loved that movie oh
my God the Uma Thurman uh what is that
shot not Sean Connery uh well Shankar is
a bad guy he's a bad guy he's the ray
fines thank you Ray fines Uma Thurman
Sean Connery blade obviously and then
Riddler's Moon I have no idea what that
is I have never heard of that well you
do is go to an unlucky
but he says
you know this guy loves Batman villains
let's give him a Riddler movie even if
that's not the Riddler that might that's
pretty much probably what happened in
Indiana a single mother lives with her
disabled soon uh with oh they meant to
say son they wrote disabled soon with
her disabled soon on a Barren Farm until
a supernatural growth spurt
reinvigorates the fields
we're really building a universe we
really are and now let's add the Clark's
three movies that Google again created
in 1990. well you know of course what I
Googled was not just best movies of 98
or movies from 1999 I had to Google
horror movies from 1998. so I found uh
yes blade blade came up as well uh but I
and H2O which is on love h2lf I very
much enjoy H2O happy Halloween mother
but the two that I was like oh yeah was
Robert Rodriguez The Faculty which is
Kevin Williamson uh doing Invasion of
the Body Snatchers which is a really it
has some unsavory words in it but uh it
overall holds up
um a really fun like fun Alien Invasion
movie and um Practical Magic which is
truly uh not nostalgically because I did
not see it in 1998 one of my uh favorite
Sandra Bullock is my my queen and that
is one of my favorite Sandy movies right
and you had that come out around the
same time as the craft and like I think
a lot of people who now talk about what
planets are in retrograde and how the
universe is shaping their future it
might have come from practical Magics
and the crafts of the world so you know
hey everybody needs something to believe
in I'm not saying I believe in that
stuff but I don't not believe it I don't
know you know Practical Magic in the
craft having an influence on a person
that doesn't sound like me
well the movie that influenced I think
maybe doesn't get its dues still even
though everybody celebrates blade
because it's a cool franchise and Wesley
Snipes as great as the character but
blade doesn't get the credit that I
think it deserves simply because it came
out in 1998 right and then the next year
we had X-Men and then we get into the
Spider-Man trilogy X-Men was 99 I
thought it was two thousand X-Men was
right on the border 99-2000. that's why
we have Brian as a producer here I think
it's I'm gonna go I think it's 2 000. I
feel like I remember anchoring that
specifically I remember reading about
X-Men in sin Escape magazine in 1999. so
that's what I'm giving her credit for it
might have been a little too crowded of
a year 99 because we did have the Matrix
as we talked about last week a little
bit we also The Phantom Menace and The
Blair Witch Project and this is really
just me showing off that I do know
movies that were released in 1999
because I do have the sinking feeling
that X-Men was in the year 2000.
July 2000 meaning we maybe got a teaser
trailer
in July thank you when I was busy not
celebrating my birthday which happens to
be July 7th if anybody would like to not
celebrate with me but I mean I think
blade does deserve uh the Lion's Share
maybe not the Lion's Share because it
wasn't the biggest movie I would give
those to the Spider-Man trilogies but
you know you you had comic book movies
come out you had Superman come out in 78
and you had Batman in 89 and every once
in a while you'd have uh either a sequel
to a Batman or a mystery man or
something pop up but then you get Blade
and it's like we could really do
something with this became a franchise
you get X-Men two years later we could
really do something that became a
gigantic franchise Spider-Man now we
have the MCU DC retooling again but a
lot of promise on the horizon so that
really was launched in Earnest in the
late 90s no absolutely I I
blade is the movie
like you said doesn't get the credit but
it's the movie that sailed a thousand
ships if you're if we're being honest
obviously X-Men was already in
production at that point but I think
seeing what can be done with blade and
maybe even getting a lit a few tweaks
out of uh because you know Spider-Man
would have been in that production
around when X-Men drops but you see both
of those and what they're doing and you
see Remy kind of adapt uh you know some
of that into the the the lifeblood of
his film and then you get one of the
greater trilogies of like life and I've
always thought Sam Ramey was such a
great director at doing that thing Clark
where he can sort of he definitely has
his own Vision his way that he wants to
make a movie but he also does even if
you look at the evil Deads and what was
happening around horror and filmmaking
at that time he does seem to have his
pulse on the public Consciousness and
the appetite of the public and so I
agree with Winston where ramy's probably
looking at the blades and the X-Men's of
the one being like okay this is some
stuff that we can incorporate into how
we're going to tell the Spider-Man story
I was also going to point out too with
blade uh rated R I mean you know that's
that's especially at the time if you're
making a rated R movie it's not like uh
it's not like something like Deadpool
now where you're like no no people will
show up right like that's a risk people
really took that rating system very
seriously especially in the 90s and so
that was a that was a big bet uh on
their part and and of course you know
blade went on to have multiple sequels
and hopefully we'll get another one from
them see you soon this holiday can we
get a camera in Clark's living room back
at the ranch in Atlanta and have it on
your dad during the Rave scene in Blade
when the Blood starts coming out
everywhere let's just see how the
Bulldog Clark Wolf's dad reacts to that
I just don't it's funny because I even
came about telling that story because
I'm in this horror movie and I've just
told my dad it's okay
you don't have to watch David Winston
can be in the lobby just buy a ticket
and then you're all good no no I'ma go
you're going but don't take me to the
one you want all your friends and family
to see because I will the hotel oh hell
no hell no no no no no no no no the
whole movie well so we talked a little
bit about where comic book movies were
and really as we know them now in their
infancy back in 98 what was the state of
horror movies as you were sort of
matriculating in your love for Horror in
the 90s Clark because around this time
you had your screams you had your I Know
What You Did Last Summer so kind of walk
in that line of Pango homage to the
slashers of the of of your but also
looking through the the lens of of like
getting into the movie and sort of
winking and nodding and a lot of comedy
in horror movies in the late 90s well
that's the thing so so really the 90s is
a weird time for horror because people
are just throwing things at the wall and
seeing what sticks you have Prestige
movies like Interview with the Vampire
which is argued like this huge literary
adaptation but also with big movie stars
taking it seriously but then you have
weird movies like mimic and like you
know it's just like and vampires
vampires are popping up all over the
place not just in like before blade
um and and as I mentioned with uh with
the interview but anyway scream comes
along and changes everything so scream
comes out Christmas
Christmas do you hear me that's why we
watch horror movies at Christmas
Christmas 97. The Exorcist famously
comes out at Christmas as well but uh
Merry Christmas
family that movie's still haunts
whatever happened to Christmas vacation
and that's wholesome I Hate My Boss
movie like what so so Brian can you can
you look up a Christmas movie that came
out in 1998 just to make Winston happy
right uh so scream comes out in uh
December 1996. changes 96 right yeah
changes everything because Scream 2 kind
of famously comes out less than a year
later uh kind of like they did just now
with Scream five and six and last summer
in between those two yes so now now
slasher movies have really had a
Resurgence but to your point you know
the idea of this slasher movies that are
winking at the audience that are
treating the audience as though they are
intelligent they know the tropes and so
that's where you get in 1998 something
like the faculty where you know again
Kevin Williamson uh it's a slasher type
of alien movie right it's a body count
movie but it is very much I mean it's a
hundred percent uh Invasion of the Body
Snatchers and Robert Rodriguez directing
something like the faculty uh he
directed The stab segments in the Scream
movies and so uh so anyway this is his
like he's getting to play in this Kevin
Williamson sandbox yeah wow I I just
because that's not something that I
would have known for obvious reasons so
it's it's nice to like kind of hear the
history of where that's going because
the obviously scream in 96 but in my
mind the the biggest horror movie of the
90s being Blair Witch a year later yeah
um to like rap out the decade you know
and so different from what was popular
at that time you know in the in the
slasher space I was just looking down
here Halloween H2O 1998 that's also
Kevin Williamson uh this is also though
Miramax this is the weinsteins you know
and so that is also something like that
scream that's uh
yeah exactly so uh so the the weinsteins
are all in on slashers Miramax and uh is
all in on this on this sub genre but
yeah Kevin has two two slasher movies
come out that year but you see these
films and and so as far as comic book
movies it's like they're just starting
to get to get their feet but it's a
car's point of the 90s man horror
franchises were running on fumes because
you had like Freddy Krueger and Jason
Voorhees and Michael Myers limping into
that decade and just trying name brand
value opening weekend hoping to muster
something and it was getting ridiculous
with how many sequels we had you had to
do something different so you could
either Lean Into The Meta which even
before scream did was Wes Craven's New
Nightmare in the mid 90s but then you
also have Howie and H2O which is like
hey we're just gonna kind of let's just
try to tell this story based off of a
previous movie so you sort of had that
recoil uh before we even had the term
that was popularized in a later Scream
movie you do also understand realizing
we're not getting enough black people
to just see if we could because real
talk I only saw that movie because all
my cousins were like yo Busta in the
movie and I was like all right and I
will never forget him the the water from
because there's a fire going happy
Halloween mother and like just otherwise
I would have nothing to do with that
okay wait I gotta do a little visual gag
here just a second okay ready the
sunglasses the glasses are coming out
well actually um Buster Rhymes it was in
Halloween resurrection which comes later
it's actually LL Cool J
he's right though she's right oh my god
well you're both right in terms of
Halloween H2 those two Halloween movies
being made by said respective hip-hop
artists LL Cool J and the fact that LL
Cool J but we talked about this movie
already Halloween H2O on the podcast so
I don't think he's that big of a spoil
for our listeners uh survives the movie
yeah LL Cool J survives the movie you
cannot understand how big that was for a
black guy to survive a horror movie so
so Scream 2 came out
so I I wonder if that was any sort of
reshoot because the amount of dragging
that Hollywood got for killing Omar and
Jada yeah in two seconds you're like
Jaden's in the movie oh Jada come on now
and insta kill I guarantee you there
must have been some sort of rewrite in
here where they were like we okay LL
needs to live we can't because when did
deep blue sea come out I was just about
to say the next
there's a weekly podcast
you should both be on it I would love to
have you but also how do you not run out
of things to talk about I'm sure he'd
love to have you to talk about Busta
Rhymes I mean LL Cool J you know in that
movie
if I don't take that shot coach pulls me
out of the game that's fair but I'll
also say 98 in terms of Comedy was a
year that I think we we had some high
water marks was there something about
Mary
um because that was sort of Apex fairly
Brothers where everything that they like
doing worked and There's Something About
Mary where you had some spoof humor you
had some genuine like rom-com
touchy-feely stuff that I thought was
really well well executed you also had
gross out humor that hit just the right
spots and I think that from There's
Something About Mary it's sort of like
how I say how great Van Halen is but it
inspired a lot of copy hair metal bands
that weren't as Soulful you you could
say the same thing about comedies after
There's Something About Mary where they
see Ben Stiller get his balls caught in
a zipper and it's like oh we need to do
that the whole movie it's like no no no
you don't need to I'm like jizz on the
forehead it's funny you mentioned all
something about Marion you earlier asked
what are these movies stood the test of
time okay you know what could never be
made today
There's Something About Mary the water
boy rush hour you're touching on a bunch
of different topics where if you even
broach the idea of of like
this is a rush hour two quote but like
I'll I'll slap you back to the Ming
Dynasty you could never say something
like that it nowadays you know what I
mean you you can't have the the sperm on
the head and the balls and the zip like
none of that is a thing you could do
anymore but this is some of the peak
slapstick kind of offensive comedy that
like you know shaped an entire
generation and just one of the hardest
laughs I've ever had in a theater was
there something about Mary and uh to
pick up Clark's Point earlier of showing
your family movies and wondering what
the result's going to be I just need to
remember at Thanksgiving when both sets
of grandparents came to visit us in
Virginia that was sort of the Midway
point so we had a bunch of family time
for Thanksgiving I was in the other room
playing Scrabble with my two grandmas
and my mom and then everybody else was
in the living room watching There's
Something About Mary on TV and I was
kind of curious to see how pop-up my
Grandpa would react to it we heard a
noise and I thought pop-up was having a
stroke I thought he was I thought he was
leaving his body that night he was just
laughing so hard at the movie he was
laughing that hard and to see how hard
my grandfather and my brother and my dad
everybody watched that movie multiple
Generations all laughing at the same
parts of the same stuff I think it was
the dog scene when they're trying to
when he's trying to revive
um and uh and again that's even a tough
scene to pull off today yeah how much we
how precious now with dogs rightly so
are in movies so it just that warms my
heart that kind of thing where you had a
peek with comedy but sometimes you just
keep pushing the envelope and I think a
lot of Comedy sense then have tried to
do it there's something about Mary did
and failed yeah I just I I again I gotta
go back to my favorite movie of all time
the fact that we'll never get another
Jackie Chan in a bar talking about
what's up my ninja
but that was literally one of the
funniest things ever because obviously
he doesn't get it he was told you
exactly what I do and he and it's if
there's no offense to it where he's
trying to be crappy he's just like oh I
don't understand culturally he said
that's how you know and it just leads to
a comedy of errors into an epic fight in
a bar like I I hate that we can't you
know we we won't necessarily find our
way back to maybe we will in a few years
but at least right now there's no way
you would see something like this in in
movies it is well it's you know it's
nice to have these movies as sort of
time capsules of where we were in 98 and
how we progressed to society and you can
always go back to those movies and watch
them but uh Clark I guess I'll start
with you what is your overall take on on
the movies the TV shows I mean again
this is when friends and and Seinfeld
was ending its run in 1998 so when you
look back on where maybe just the
broader Strokes of entertainment were in
1998 what do you think of I see the end
and beginning of a cycle you know truly
like uh the arguably you're phasing out
things like Seinfeld friends and Will
and Grace have a few more years but like
if Seinfeld is sort of the continuation
not literally but of the of the sitcom
of Cheers of this and it's it's sort of
in a way subverting the tropes of a
sitcom right because cause that's the
whole point is you hate these people and
it's a show about nothing in the same
way that scream would kind of take the
Baton exactly okay and then I'm seeing
here also you know A Bug's Life which is
to me uh one of the first Pixar movies
that I remember being like whoa I think
that was number two on top of that right
because it was right after a Toy Story
Toy Story Bug's Life than uh Monsters
Inc right so it's like we're in this
sort of we're in this sort of yes it's
not the first but we're solidifying what
this is um and uh and we're seeing you
know things like uh like again Wild
Things comes out this year that also
feels like truly in terms of style of
movie that feels like a like something
from a before time that's kind of
crossing over so that is to me the thing
that stands out here is is the end of
1998 and that's probably why 1999 is so
revered because we're seeing sort of the
a true culmination of a change in cinema
um and and pop culture I I think I just
can't Shake sports right now this is
this is your Championship round that you
didn't quite get to the big dance the
big game and then next year is when you
finally like get to get the belt no this
is Jordan losing to the Pistons this is
losing to the Pistons and then finally
getting by the bad boys and then getting
the title like this this you're exactly
right this is the setup for that full
success because you're even looking at
near the end of just straight Disney
Animation uh as is you still get a few
but like Mulan one of the last great
Classics of that Disney Animation style
before they really lean into Pixar right
and The Prince of Egypt which was not
Disney but it was still like straight
animation but it just it was the bugs
the Bug's Life and ants sort of got the
The Lion Share of the of the the
excitement for where animated films
could go back in 1998 and then 99 you
also had that that's that easy
juxtaposition in 99 where it's like The
Phantom Menace and it costs so much
money and we put so much into this and
then you also have the Blair Witch
Project which was like you know we paid
five dollars right and everybody thought
that movie was like real for like the
first week and like what are we watching
it's not real oh boy I was gonna say we
last week we talked about Keanu Reeves
movies and we talked about The
Replacements which is 2000 uh and when I
was watching re-watching that movie and
there's the dance sequence which we also
talked about last week I thought of
There's Something About Mary because of
the credits is the sing-along and so and
I there were a handful of things there I
was like oh and you know we the the
knockoff thing of like oh this was super
this was very popular and successful in
in something here and then we see it
repeated over and over again and
actually now that I'm looking at this
list I can see those influences but yeah
that's so funny that like actually stood
out to me when I was re-watching the
replacement every time I hear Build You
Up Buttercup by the foundations I still
think of the end credits of There's
Something About Mary um also a couple
great uh rom-com romantic you know
slanted movies How Stella Got Her Groove
Back came out that summer and then you
have the uh you've got mail which
ironically might be the movie that
stands the test of time the most along
with How Stella Got Her Groove Back just
because we can always fall in love with
somebody regardless of whether it's the
very early days of AOL you also you had
the big bookstore coming in taken away
the mom and pop bookstore and you've got
mail it just again it's a great movie
for no other reason because Meg Ryan and
Greg Kinnear have the single most
amicable breakup that I've ever seen on
screen because they just show up to a
bar and they're just talking like yeah
is it not worry for you not working for
me all right well hey fist bump we gave
it a good run I've broken up with people
like in real life that nicely but I've
never seen it on screen that well it was
it was something to Aspire to dude you
got mail from me this is this is Peak um
Dave Chappelle is like the black best
friend that like loves just dropping
little little jokes here and there and
yeah just push great service in that
movie because because you had that you
had him in Robin Hood Men in Tights
previously as a chew you know yeah
underrated gag in that movie he's got
he's got I think he's got Reebok Pumps
he is like feather cap is a backwards
hat yeah
I am at you and his father is a sneeze
which is the challenge
um but I gotta talk about one of the
greatest directors of all time and Spike
Lee puts out He Got Game and you bring
Denzel into this film with the about to
be uh you know Hall of Famer uh as he's
really getting introduced to the league
Ray Allen as Jesus shutters
Shuttlesworth and one of the best
stories that Spike has told and really
what that movie was able to do and
really kind of bring to audiences that
maybe don't know a lot of like that kind
of history of how that might happen for
somebody on that trajectory and to see
Ray Allen have a performance like that
absolutely so precocious who would have
known that some 15 years later he just
ripped my spurs loving heart out by
hitting that shot I will never get over
why Tim Duncan wasn't on the floor to
get the rebound and secure the
Championship we got our Vengeance the
next year I'll be fine ask is He Got
Game the reunion of Spike Lee and Mel
and after Malcolm X and Denison after
that's so that's a huge moment right to
to have them coming back together on
screen if that's that's yeah it's a big
year it was a good year for Cinema
obviously a great year for Rotten
Tomatoes because they were born we were
it was our impetus on August 18th and
now we have Rotten Tomatoes we got the
books like the broad movies we love and
Rotten Tomatoes the card game it's a
really fun game to play it's a good uh
drinking game it's a good game to play
with your family there's a lot of
different out like owies and Alleyways
you can take with the Rotten Tomatoes
card game so check that out can't get
out of here and go to mailbag before I
remind everybody that there were actual
Christmas movies that came out in 1998
such as okay well Clark's family is
going to watch this this year Bride of
Chucky came out
for Winston don't worry the Jonathan
Taylor Thomas classic I'll Be Home for
Christmas that's a banger look I'm right
here I'm looking right here down the
prettiest family movies one of the
greatest Christmas movies of all time
and it's one of the things that actually
helped me and my girlfriend really get
as close as we are now is is her insane
love for jtt and uh me for different
reasons but that man is America's
sweethearter he was for at least five or
six years
so sorry that movie's so good that is
how you know that that takes me back to
a time and place because the fact that I
this was when I kind of grew out of
Jonathan Taylor Thomas because I did not
see I'll Be Home for Christmas but when
Tom and Huck came out just a few years
ago earlier you know I was there yeah
you had a jtt calendar
Jonathan Taylor Thomas
that's why I remember because I was like
that's my dog and Jessica bielberg
himself Gary Cole great comedic actor
pops in and the Tomato Meter says oh 23
41 with the audience which includes
Winston and his incredible Alexis will
come back we'll do Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong for Christmas movies and you can
do I'll Be Home for Christmas I'll do
the conjuring too and that we've got the
show all please get on the limb and say
that Friday After Next is riding and so
I'm going to staunchly defend that that
will be that will this will be my
runner-up for sure but I gotta and we
have all these talking points again
thanks to sen Duong and his idea to make
this thing called Rotten Tomatoes way
back in 1998. it's just so wonderful
having Clark and Winston back uh Clark
we got the big movie that you're
starring in malum coming out in theaters
Nationwide tomorrow so people can grab
their tickets and go see it wherever you
are in the country go check out malum
please do if you're if you're in
interested in supporting you know
independent cinema it really makes a
difference if you go see this one in the
theater because it's actually getting a
theatrical run so it was made with a lot
of love despite how scary this movie is
it's very
and Winston probably run into the lobby
within 15 minutes with Clark's dad so uh
when we can't catch you in a horror
movie where can we catch you what you up
to absolutely you can find me all over
the internet at the Swaggy blurred uh go
check out my YouTube channel I got a lot
of great reviews over there got my uh I
forgot to mention this last week my
Watch the Throne uh Bel Air review
podcast we dive into the episodes but a
lot of the uh discussion of like the
story lines that they're presenting and
you know what that means to the black
community and things like that so
definitely check that out see me on
capes and cows over with Christian
harloff and that's pretty much it right
now y'all got any TV you're watching
that you're excited about yes sorry
ladies first very energetically party
down yeah oh you found party down
welcome well no the new episodes wait
wait what oh it's back what it's back
there's Billboard's all over season
three this is why I am telling people
because no one knows and y'all this new
episodes most of the cast Lizzy kaplan's
the only one who's not back because she
was shooting something else y'all it is
so if you were a fan of the original
series this is just the perfect show to
the Perfect cast to Usher back into a
Revival uh it's funnier it's it's funny
as ever same with South Park South
Park's also back and I am just as my
little comedy nuggets that I enjoy every
Saturday anything with Kevin Moreno in
it I'm gonna watch so party down on the
list Winston you counter with what uh I
mean there's there's obviously all of
the the main Staples that everybody's
talking about so the White Lotus is The
Last of Us Severance all that I'm gonna
give you a nugget that you maybe aren't
paying enough attention to and that's
shrinking on Apple TV plus oh yeah
Harrison Ford Jason Siegel at the uh
Jessica Williams my uh my uh Groundlings
teacher she's killing it with her
recurring guest star but it is so good
and it genuinely gets to it it reminds
me a lot of what weeds did early on uh
where you're using dark comedy to really
address grief and how that affects
yourself how it affects your family how
it can affect parenting or being raised
by someone that is going through the
similar grief that you are it is so well
done and I cannot speak higher of it and
it also has um oh my goodness Brett
Goldstein who's Roy Kent in Ted lasso
he's one of the executive producers on
the show as well so you're getting a lot
of heartfelt uh energy into that show
there you go my buddy comedian Matt
Knudson also in shrinking so check that
out on Apple TV and as for me I'm just
here to stunt for Rotten Tomatoes and
their 25th birthday unlike me they
actually celebrate it and they're doing
so all year long August 18th is the
official day but you can go to rt.com
shop and pick up the Rotten Tomatoes
card game fun with your family with your
friends with your drinking buddies as
Winston the van on my Pat Sajak is
modeling it so well in Clark with the
dead on studio audience reactions as we
say good night here for Jacqueline Coley
I am Mark Ellison the whole gang here at
Rotten Tomatoes and Rotten Tomatoes dot
com thank you and we'll continue to
enjoy the birthday celebration all the
live long year happy 25th Rotten
Tomatoes
[Music]